hey guys hey Gregory here I'm John John
and Gregor here text messages going off
in the computer yeah
guys guys guys it's been a long time
since we had a movie in the states of
the ring ring we're back now rings it's
been how many years since what rent the
ring was what 2002 was it yeah mm too
early the ring too came out a few years
later not too many people really dug it
no I think in terms of plot it's kind of
cool as an execution I remembered I only
saw that one time in the theaters I
didn't see the you didn't see it I
didn't see the ring - no I saw the ring
you made me watch the ring in the dark
and I was terrified
hey I was talking with someone about a
yesterday I will never watch them I saw
the ring twice not gonna watch it again
that like twisted up face thing just
[ __ ] me up anyway this is rings let's
check this [ __ ] out
not real
[ __ ] back mm-hmm modern date last
night
come on we gotta get up blue happy
couple
I keep thinking about this story there's
this video email change things that
kills you
seven days after you watch it yes [ __ ]
the the second silver and phone rings
that's when she's coming for me you want
to know about the girl Oh what does she
want from me this mark on your hand
it says rebirth she wants to be born
again
so here
you've opened up the door and I no one
is safe ha ha ha
rings on a plane
ah whoa what are they trying to
accomplish there yeah yeah I mean I was
nuts of it this is a cool trailer I'm a
little I don't know how that's gonna go
the ring on a plane is like really cool
but also seems kind of wacky
the first thing I'm thinking about is
Vincent o3o really became someone
special amongst people like my age
because of his role in daredevil okay
that's kingpin yeah and now he's a blind
guy he keeps me put up in these horns
said this on rogue one oh good I'm gonna
say here now the blind community is
gonna get very upset soon that they're
not casting real blind people because
the blind is in right now
blind is in okay so we got daredevil we
got stick we got the movie don't breathe
with Stephen Lang as a blind guy Donnie
yen's playing the blind guy and road one
the woman in a Dairy God Deadpool
Deadpool Deadpool and now Vincent
d'Onofrio's a blind nad I needed another
punchline to end this um
seeing is believing Haley's immune from
the ring it's great for him he could no
but I bet I just bet you two like he's
seen the tape before and that's why he's
blind there's something okay pause it is
real fast I like some of the effects I
think so the effects are really cool
when your hands are together
anything with pulling stuff out of your
throat like that like anytime they do
that in movies I'm especially impressed
yeah and and that's a cool thing about
j-horror to me is is when they work in
that sort of weird body or stuff that's
yeah odd there's always a moment to
shower or something messed up happens
and I like that almost always reminded
me of Silent Hill when her hands are
melting together Oh spooky stuff in this
trailer I think is really cool it's
really it's a torturing woman yeah yeah
I always take a shower scene a torture a
woman because it's nothing more
vulnerable than a naked chick that's
gonna be my J horror movies gonna have a
dude showers I really hope this movie
isn't just about what if you know mood
out with the Internet yeah what if you
was in an email but the one of you is on
a plane what if your childhood is a nap
what are ya now the reapers everywhere
and actually that could be that could be
pretty crazy but that would be a whole
other like film though I think we would
have to be like this is the end of your
French eyes right here well yeah and
that's what this trailer gives to me is
I'm sort of like hey all this stuff
could be really cool it could also be I
could kind of crumble under the way to
like this stuff like I don't know like
that could be pretty scary if you know
think about like an epidemic of virus
spreads of this video to everyone and
then then probably not tomorrow is in
more places than once this is definitely
got potential I this is one of those
trailers that piques my interest I'm
definitely interested to see where it
goes and I don't know if I'm like this
is gonna be amazing
and it's totally a reboot yeah it's
definitely like a reboot me as much I'm
gonna call it ring cuz it technically is
like picking up after ring too however
it's not about continuing the story of
Naomi Watts as characters brand new
attractive white cup yeah well Naomi
Watts killed it I has such a big crush
on Naomi Watts after watching the rings
such a big crush one she wasn't wrong I
designed um when I was really young
watching that movie that one scene where
she's changing just turned Braun
underwear I'm just like damn this
so [ __ ] hot and beautiful then I saw
King Kong love during it too not sure
when it was where I stashed losing
interest in her but I started losing
interest in her but the ring definitely
helped me know yeah yeah on her
potential now you she's a tremendous
actress no matter where she is but
that's what I liked about the ring
cuz this but what you might say about
its character development and whatnot it
had a character in it where it allowed
Namie
Naomi Watts to shine the land Naomi
Watts to give a performance well it was
one of those convincing like that's the
kind of performance I always like and
when you get a great actor to do it like
when you watch someone deteriorate over
the course of a Fafi and just get worse
and worse always impressive thing to me
and I like when these movies do that
yeah it seems like we're gonna get a lot
of that here with especially the way I
don't know if they're gonna put that
into the movie but the way they cut this
trailer the whole like day one day two
and does the day's keep getting more and
more [ __ ] up that's something exciting
I would actually love it if they brought
Naomi Watts back like halfway through
and kept that kind of like a secret to
everyone that she wasn't it I wish they
would bring her back as like whatever
they're doing with Vincent Afra I wish
she would come back as like the one who
can help you yeah like through this I
think that would be quie Vincent off we
go like any time I see him in a film I'm
just excited
I don't everyone talk [ __ ] about his
dress and world character definitely
more on the writing than his performing
yeah it's not getting a character but he
does a good job he does a good job and I
still think he's always a delight to
watch I think he's a really cool [ __ ]
actor I loved him on long or criminal
intent you ever see him on that yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] dude so anything he does
I'm gonna be there just because I really
like watching Vincent and offer you know
you say does comparing like these weird
kind of horror films like he's always in
the horror movie as as you know the guy
who we turn to who's an expert who can
help us shed some light on it is always
cool like he always brings something to
it doesn't seem like he just goes on
autopilot I get the sense that these are
fun roles for him I feel like this movie
though so far it's like the Cho just
wants to show us like that fun scares
will be there but if you look at the
plot of the ring 1 & 2 I don't even see
a ring - so I'm gonna spoil it for you
want to be her son or something like
that yeah takeovers but in the first one
when that movie ends
she ends with
aidan the son copying the tape and then
after they copy the tape that sounds
like what were we gonna do now Naomi
watch this character
their names Rachael is pretty much
original in the first one she decides
this is just gonna live on we just got
to get it out of our lives but it's
still gonna live on second one it's more
like I'm gonna shut this [ __ ] down it's
not about that the whole time but you
know it by the end it pretty much is
becoming about like I'm gonna close the
lid on this well you know cuz if it
comes back then you're like okay the Zen
approach does not work yeah exactly kiss
no she's always gonna come back so I
don't know what happens I would like it
to still be connected to that though is
in my opinion Rachael saved the day and
she sealed though the well she steals
more on that well in my recollection I
think it ends on a good note to like a
personal Ned's on like I kind of doubt
that one ends like on a good note like
she has Aidan back and yeah I said ñ
even though he'd installer' died in it
I'm really ruining the movie for you so
good I'm not - Simon - baker's of it is
you real I hope they bring some of that
stuff back I don't I don't know what you
want to know why it's out there I want
to know why it's still out there yeah I
mean this makes again there are a lot of
copies of it still floating around but
that I mean someone have to gone into
the whip somebody would have had to
reserve your universe kind of don't make
sense
now I want to know what they're gonna do
with the rules of like yeah who took the
time to like you know digitally transfer
this from tape on computer like who
spent time on this and why and now that
it's you know out apparently everywhere
how do we copy it so I'm just curious as
to how they explain it cuz they very
well might have a good explanation cuz
this looks like and updated the ring
yeah it looks a modern version of the
ring which is cool but I also need to
see if these characters are gonna be
compelling if the stories yeah be good I
get the sense that this is gonna be a
cool horror movie with some spooky
j-horror [ __ ] I don't know much beyond
that from this yeah cuz I really hope
it's not just about tactical scares that
was one thing I've really admired about
the ring there's like an actual story
here that like you find
pelling in the twist in the turns yeah
understanding and it's about recently
then when I remember the first one dude
the first time I've told you about what
my dad saw the ring right I think so but
refresh my memory right now tell the
viewers at home my one of my favorite
memories of my father was the first time
he saw the ending to the ring we were
watching in my living room because we
rented it like Odyssey video so we had
like for another day and my dad's kind
of guys like we'll just keep [ __ ]
rewatching but he didn't watch it Sam I
already was on the lunar floor watching
it he falls asleep I remember yeah 30
minutes before the movies gonna end he
wakes up and decides that I'll just
finish the movie and he doesn't what's
going on all I knows is about some
videotape and then he fell asleep
so that moment where some Versamark
comes out of the well and she starts
walking towards the TV and then her hand
comes out yeah my dad was like famous
boxers late on the flipper like
comfortable all the sudden start
freaking out and going aren't pointing
at the TV as if it was happening to him
back yeah
those brilliant never been done now they
really capitalize on that now they've
led with that it is like your husband
yeah oh yeah which at which I couldn't
help but think like how she gonna get
out of this she's gonna have to like
lift it up it's gonna be really awkward
for her bi what is she doing out I don't
floor and just sit on the plasma she'll
stay down and it seems like she's done
this enough times as you can just kind
of wonder stir I'm wondering cuz they
have Sadiq Khan vs. Qaeda Co now in
Japan and I think that's coming to
America and they embraced the quirkiness
of that it seems like and they had fun
with it I hope this one you know is
markedly scary I know wants to be scary
and if it is this way I hope it's a
little self-aware like inches down just
let's add a little self aware of what's
going on because you feel like in
franchises now you kind of have to be
yeah especially with this one it's like
don't take yourself that serious yeah
it's like if you're doing a new version
of a notable franchise property
now you should be a little self-aware I
think because there's all that stuff
about like well why not just make a new
movie and call it something else
Aidan should come back you should you
should ain't your Tom back or or he
should be played by like DJ cotrona gee
that's you ain't girl ooh the clueless
so after the dramatic ghost offensive it
just work out now yeah sleep a woman
yeah got a little life after nearly
dying on 11 years old and get your balls
screwed on yeah let's put that table did
you put that table on hosting yeah
intense and cool grown-up I don't
believe this I don't believe this they
added some stuff to the tape yeah it
looks like this Mara went through iMovie
Vidya knows modern-day technology I can
really make enhancements taursus it
seems like it's kind of simplifying the
plot a little more because I don't
remember the first trailers doing stuff
like day 1 day 2 day 3 like breaking
that down it was more about the story at
hand yeah it was counting down but I
remember that being used in effect kind
of like oh yeah [ __ ] with diarrhea I
don't know if they're gonna incorporate
that in the movie I liked it it's
different cuz that's a part of the the
cool part like you said about the
original range like you have to kind of
jog your memory and wonder about how
much time is left either definitely
going with a different vibe with this or
they can keep it more low budget this
way they can keep the French it's coming
easily the first ring even though he
wasn't a huge director at the time it
was directed by Gore Verbinski when it
feels like as I recalled the ring it
feels like a film yeah that's why I mean
it's beautifully shot it's beautifully
shot yeah like it feels like a very
genuine kind of somber movie yeah and
even though they got the original
director from the ring from ring or ring
you I do to do the ring too in America I
still thought the first ring was was
much better I thought most people did it
yeah I haven't heard many great things
about the ring true America one Japanese
here oh no we totally got it from you
guys hey man I mean like I've heard a
fair number one
ring where j-horror has gone at least in
America so it would be cool to have it
come back for a little bit laugh at a
cat someone who looks so much like
Jessica I know that's doing like her
scene from the I in the show you might
as well have just gotten Jessica Alba to
be unless she's not doing anything I'll
definitely be there to watch it it looks
it looks like it's be entertain we're
gonna go watch don't breathe sometime
soon hopefully if you do I'm gonna see
the [ __ ] out of don't breathe this we
got that's the most accessible removable
I'm going tonight by myself
mark like a Hollywood eight 15 lucky
duck
be there or be pulp fiction well thanks
for tuning in to the channel if you like
to subscribe to things and be notified
anytime there's something new out from
us doesn't that sound fun I bet you
don't have enough of those you need more
in that spam folder subscribe to the
real rejects do yourself a big favor
John is my friend best friend brother in
heart and arms and blood DNA composed
together spliced I love him just like
the movie splice reasons to Jerry is his
Twitter and Instagram handle he also
does the social media managing of
facebook.com slash blue house and our
real rejects site and the Twitter of the
real rejects hip that's why I'm giving
John Craig because there was this guy
shout-out to JSP HGD Henze this guy's
had some rude things on my Instagram I
saw that on his Instagram he says stupid
since 1997 as his description goofy and
I really capitalize on the fact that he
views himself as stupid after he
insulted me and then I even took a
screenshot of it and posted it on
Instagram and it's traumatic it down
because it violated their Community
Guidelines dude always with the
Community Guidelines fair now I'm not
one to apologize on camera in person all
the time
suddenly I'm the most apologetic I know
it goes on camera no II go all the way
so cheese vagc NZ is a big deal for you
man I got carried away I took out a lot
of my aggression on you because you're
being a [ __ ] ass I'm sorry